[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody to the water zone
meeting for Monday the 6th of July it
has been some time since we've been here
I think early March was the last time we
had the ability to all meet in person
I'm gonna skip on the carrot here
because we have
our putter away so just like a king
welcome you all to this meeting we have
to put up with this annoying background
hum as part of the covert regulations
that
public meetings are recorded so we just
have to work through with that so if I
can requesting any committee members
when you're speaking to make sure you
use your mics please
all right I'll move straight to one
point two which is apologies
[Music]
I've gotta cut a ribbon please
sorry I demand an apology I have to
leave up five if we're still going then
okay so we've got our pot of Reuben
l-e-d that we have windy
Aaron and Sandra have all submitted
their apologies
a mover please
cam thank you Sikandar John
all those in favor
whatever came I think we'll just do a
quick whip around the room if you could
just lead off on the introductions
please
surely a camera innocent deputy chair
for the Sun committee and community
member
[Music]
Dignan counsel
Judith repellency
jong-kook Naidu who didi reeling a rib
David HP community member
[Music]
I'm Michael Blackwell current chair and
if we could just carry on with you
Michael Bates and run them through the
room from the event
thank you for that
right on point for registrations of
interest is there any changes or updates
please
item two opportunity for the public to
speak we
any members of public auto
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so Michael Sophie's got a presentation
shortly on the carpet like I said that
who answer me some of your questions
Linda Adrian just with regard to
saltwater intrusion have you got
anything to add with the data loggers by
the bridge please
the short answer is we we've had a data
logger in the whole year we haven't
managed to get the data out out of it to
be able to report here today apologies
for that
but really I would like to respond to
you a little bit Michael on these things
I think the first thing is the macro
fights the wheat beats and all these
waterways is an important part of the
ecosystem and it's important we're
talking about biological systems here so
we're talking about the system isn't
trying to understand how resilient they
are in terms of the Chi boy River and
your photographs it's excellent and
great that we're seeing these wheat weed
beds reestablishing these micro fights
growing and the ecosystems looking a lot
healthier I've been observing them
regularly since probably
probably September last year during the
whitebait season and they were worth
they were group they were starting to
grow back really well then and they've
developed all the way through till now
and that's great that's a good news
story the river is developing a lot more
resilience back in your thesis is that
it's it's all driven by herbicides or no
herbicides I've previously presented to
the zone committee that there are other
stresses on these rivers in particularly
salt water that in the past has really
not that I believe is not things really
badly on a couple of the years in the
last and the last sort of eight or ten
years we've had very long periods of low
flow in the way mccreery we've had salt
water coming up for very long periods
and these weed beds can cope with it
with a degree of salt you know a few
days here and there and things like that
but they don't cope well with a with a
month or two months of salt water being
regularly on them and looking at and
looking at this year
even the Waimakariri River
sort of flow regime that's not
indicating to me that we would have had
that sort of long periods of low flow
we've been having two or three floods or
fresh you know small at least small
floats or freshest and the way mccreary
every month this year so therefore we
haven't had those conditions for the
salt water to be sort of poisoning the
weed in that way but just recovery
remembering that these are ecosystems
the wheat bits are quite resilient to
certain things and they're being
influenced by the more nutrients
sediment the salt water and the
herbicides and things like that
and if they all line up the wrong way
they get killed off like we've seen in
the past
whichever one might be dominant on
killing them off as a moot point we
could debate but really I think the
take-home message here is that it's
great we're seeing the wee bits back in
the Copper River it's great that we're
seeing a healthier system there and the
challenges to try to keep all of those
sort of issues end to to sort of keep
the river healthy and I'm sure you'll
agree that we'd like to see it healthier
I will come back to the zone committee
in the next month in the you know in the
next meeting or to weather with the
heart salinity data and we still are
also progressing with knee where I'm
trying to get a model of it so we can
predict what though what these certain
salient situations will be but I think
I'd never say that salt water alone is
going to be the killing killing factor
for macro fights but it but it can be an
important one lining up with other
things
the chem river floodgates
that's an issue I know you've had
different meetings have had Brian
McIndoe who was the flood engineer he's
he retired just before covert and Fred
Brooks has taken over from him and I'm
assuming we can come back to this
committee and talk about that at some
stage we certainly gave a commitment to
scope that with those issues and have a
look at it some more but it is a major
undertaking to both modify the flood
gates to make them electronic but also
they're consented as a peak flood piece
of infrastructure not as a tide gate
sort of infrastructure so we are scoping
it but it's not a it's not a fact matter
of just
carrying out that modification overnight
that would need a quite a detailed
consenting an approval process with the
end including the different people's
views because they were there they're
operated maybe two to five percent of
the time for critical floods and the
waymaker Erie River to protect against
that they're not there as a tight gate
at the moment and we are working on
there
Oh
[Music]
Oh exactly I think everyone wants a
healthy River Michael
[Music]
okay now you're right Mike thank you for
those comments Andrew can I just ask you
to pass that sedimentation overflow from
reading books on to Marco just just for
a wee inquiry that would be thanks for
bringing that to our attention Michael
I'd like to know what the deal is here
thanks very much for you
mr. chairman
but follow up this
just wondering perhaps
observations receipt
[Music]
it's showing us
well the Oh item 3 which is the coop or
Lakes update Sophia look you happen to
be right there
[Music]
great this ties in very well with it
follows on from Michael Bates talk about
the Caillou Lakes so I believe this was
a request from the zoning committee last
meeting to talk about
we were we were at with the Caillou
lakes what sort of management has
happened in the last few years and
you're definitely the sigh bacterial
blooms that have had the last two
summers so I've got Adrian Meredith here
as well who his longer history with me
then
on the Cape we lakes and so you
definitely had to a lot of background
but the stood locate where we are
talking about this is the the main row
north and kiya poi and the two lakes
with the red dots WDC managed so our
green space team look after the park
area around open to the public there's a
private lakes to the north their term
have a subdivision around and they
privately managed the lake later you can
just see to the north west an area that
is his willows that's an undeveloped WDC
lake
his no public access but his book shade
[Music]
and just noting noting for context to
going through this talk that two red
dots are the other lakes but the lake
above then the lake on the rock on the
right is contiguous with that with the
lake above so yes so that's part of the
of the lake below it as well they
continue us through their chain of words
so the WDC minute it's a win we're
talking about the subdivision lakes
they're just the one right just creeping
off the top of this slide
great so there's been quite a bit of
management of these lakes in the last 10
years or so instead of a potted summary
we've had willows removed from the
western lake
we've had what a weed management and the
Westerbeck so that's worth not with
herbicide but with a weed cutter boat
that came from Christchurch City Council
and looking into why green space carried
out their work they said it's because
they had a request from the fishermen in
order to be able to help them with their
course fishery of Tinch
things approach there as well
we have looked but not carry out any
works to look at the sludge layer that
was building out it was partly from sign
of bacterial bloom scoping so it was
green space who initially initiated that
but we thought it wasn't actually
appropriate for the measurement of the
lakes I can go into
currently we're looking at aeration for
the algal bloom management and that's
because the private lakes to the north
have had an aerator in place for
ten years or so and it has been
successful
preventing sign of bacterial blooms I
should know that they also they do have
other blooms of dinoflagellates for
example which may look bad but more
really colored bloom but they're not
toxic we've had teams translocated into
lakes so we do have fishermen Fisher
persons who use light quite regularly
playground next door so when we have had
this I know bacterial blooms who have
posted signage to sweet they will know
that they shouldn't ever come in contact
with the water or eating the fish from
the area during the times
hidsim by security
to remove below curb we do have as Linda
Pocock was questioning we do have some
spraying around the lake with our parks
management I haven't actually looked
until me that it's possible that some
over spraying could have occurred that's
a good question
but in summary the last 10 years we
haven't had any chemical usage or
[Music]
yeah any chemical usage or herbicide
usage in the those two publicly owned
lakes
yeah as Michael Bates showed this is
that was the bloom this year quite
significant so this is a novena or golly
Casper moments another name for it now
which is a toxic sign of bacteria and it
does it is quite visible
when you when you do get the
pelant looms but this is just one pie
the lake where it accumulates from the
winds the whole Lake doesn't look like
this but it's deep
hums these blooms did when they become
when they've grown into a bloom they
tend to be very buoyant sort of the
surface so the wind tends to blow them
and they concentrate a one in 2022 the
lake which is what their photograph is
showing if the wind moves from that was
probably a more westerly pushing it to
the western side of the lake if it then
moves to leastly it may push the bloom
to the other side of the lake so we're
seeing it really concentrated often by
the wind as well in the recreational
areas
so for it covered a bit about the
Northern Lakes which have private so
just moving on to the council managed to
do okay sorry sorry that probably had
biggest learnings are the two deepest
lakes on the butch was the cowboy Lake
subdivision which was developed around
fifteen years ago and these these are
deeper than the Waimakariri district
lakes once about five meters deep one's
about fifteen meters deep we were called
in
in 12 years ago when they when they were
started to get toxic blooms particularly
in the autumn
along the lines of what you see in those
photos and community and public health
were busy pudding so what top toxic
warning science on the front lawns of
these sort of very expensive properties
and they like subdivision
they called us in to help them find a
solution to this we explored a load of
options with them and basically we're as
they trialed a couple of cheaper options
we have each lee said the biggest issue
is
these Lakes layering having losing all
the oxygen in the bottom in the autumn
that layering start to break down bring
all the nutrients to the surface and the
toxic algal blooms grow
they trialed initially with a very cheap
compressor in found they didn't hit the
blooms anymore you know over time and
they've they put in a much more larger
commercial presser in the inner just a
small narration amps on in both lakes
and they haven't had a bloom sense
pretty much as a community they're very
much happy with that solution
great then on the eastern side of the
main road the council lake beer there is
the potentially some impact from the old
kind
there is monitoring in place
we carry our Justin
see if we want to think they might have
and potentially some storm would have
run off which has means that there was a
bit of a higher nutrient load into those
Lakes
that is slightly there's not quite as
deep as those private lakes and that's a
bit of an issue if you are looking at
aeration for consideration as Adrienne
was saying is works to break up those
layers and if you don't get those those
different layers forming in a lake the
stratification then you get loads of
different reasons so that's why it's
probably more important to get
data this summer we're proposing to put
in some dissolved oxygen probes
it can have volunteered to help us worth
while to supply so yeah it's a bit of a
question of whether these Lakes with
their slightly shallower dips are also
suitable for aeration
finally on the western side we have very
shallow only once to immunity Sandra in
areas which
although we had a bloom in the last two
years I'm guessing the aeration wouldn't
be suitable at all because you would get
suitable turnover from from wind for
example stimulates the breaking these
aloof
play as you get so there might be a
different solution that we need
we're trying to
so anything you know to add Adrienne
before I open questions
probably just make a point that we're
dealing with with small isolated lakes
here and that have been that were
probably there
to some extent artificial and generated
around the time of the first building
the
northern motorway back in the sort of
late 60s early 1970s therefore they've
been evolving since they were first
formed generally none of them have a
sort of outlet stream or anything like
that so they're self-contained they're
slowly getting runoff from all the
surrounding areas coming into them and
the nutrient status is just increasing
over time they're not an aesthetic
situation so they're becoming more and
more nutrient-enriched some of them
slowly on that on the western side some
of them may be a little bit faster on
the eastern side and what we're seeing
now is probably them in it reaching a
critical stage where they starting to
generate these problems and I think what
Sophie you you know what you and I
discussing a lot and as a council you're
trying to decide what is the solution to
sort of maintain them in a better state
so they remain as a community easy
yes let's see what we were looking for
this summer is do we get a very low
oxygen people right at the bottom of
those lakes and if so that means that
the aeration is probably suitable
but we also there are some symptoms that
michaelbay traces that Fishkill
that you noticed Ottoman as we mentioned
about 9 to 12 years ago that is a
typical symptom of low oxygen levels in
the bottom of the water so it's
interesting that that was in the
shallower Lake
[Music]
like I said that me my bike that you
know it means that there are low oxygen
levels we're not sure it might not be
doing a stratification it could be very
very high oxygen demand
yeah so we're slightly harder to to
the slide here if you wanted to do
anything about the time
velji
these are the sort of results we get
from from Coral Institute or
or new or new wire depending on which
the term and the agency is and then
they'll give us a letter and they'll
identify the species and the lists and
this one's showing there are a number of
sign of bacterial species that normally
occur probably the top two of the other
critical ones Dalek is firm or otherwise
known as a novena is the internationally
toxic one it was in the highest numbers
there and it's probably Chinnery
regenerating most of that greenness
although a fennec EPSA the top one in
that list is equally a toxic one as well
and therefore I'm probably illustrating
here you get multiple species it's it's
often never simply once it's frequently
never simply one species and then others
below there P cosine a bacteria pseudo a
novena and I would even try to pronounce
the the bottom one as sort of a tracers
there but generally often not
particularly toxic or not toxic at all
but once again we're dealing with
ecosystems were dealing with a whole
bunch of species and what we're trying
to do is reduce one or two species that
are that are becoming a
Adrian can it be you know how it blows
to one side can it be filtered off
filtered offal vacuumed up
probably the short answer is yes it
could be but I don't think people people
it's it's generally prevention as better
than a treating a symptom like that it
just it is largely fine cellular
material so it's quite difficult to
actually um to actually bring it
together that you know as you can see
from that you're talking about thousands
of cells right there so it's not like
breaking in the the micro fights or
anything like that
to clear micro fights it's a it's a very
fine suspension slurry of ourselves
you're never going to get them all and I
think all of the mechanisms that Sophie
and I are talking about and that true to
Lake management is try to stop it
blooming in the first place and find a
solution
rather than treated after explode
the questions I don't think you can
mention it that's are they fed by
groundwater I mean thinking how the
Pegasus like you just cut into the
groundwater and you're actually picking
up groundwater from the plains which is
as opposed to
so they are cut into the groundwater
particularly the kuiper Lakes
Subdivision Lakes when we were talking
to them and their lakes are deeper yeah
there were sooted there was certainly a
not only a strong groundwater flow that
maintains all of these lakes but in
their lakes they were intercepting
several of our peat layers as well in
that area they were mining sort of very
fine pea gravels and grits that were
being used to versus of batching
concrete and things for the motorway and
those who are into spacing the sort of
pea gravels and grits in peat layers and
things like that you're often getting
that sort of and some of us getting some
anoxic water or carbon rich water as
well coming through coming through into
these Lakes
so it can be that the water is reduced
groundwater therefore the nitrate levels
can be quite low but the phosphorus is
what usually is the problem
the phosphorus will be held by the
sediment in as
you mentioned it's not leaving and so
when you get low oxygen people to get
release of the phosphorus proper
sediment and that drives the often the
so bacteria chemically
from the Year nitrogen from the year the
nitrogen fixers what about the overall
management of the lakes I mean
assisting the ecosystem and planting yes
you know even the tire just
has been seen in quite as their
management aim
yes ideally we'd we'd cover which would
prevent
booms but you get that like flipping
where the algal blooms bent the weep
gross and so it could be that it looks
like the weeds have been sprayed but
actually it's because the algae are
shaving them out and it's when you get
lakes that become Elmi dominated rather
than
that's deeply something we're trying to
avoid but I'm just thinking what is that
what did what do you want the lake what
it's you that counts a lot the lakes to
look like you want them to be surrounded
by tall and emergent you know macro
facts and tall emergent and
vegetation it can be
planting trees to get shading you know
just what's the ecological target aim
as opposed to park
yeah whether the lakes are big enough
that you'll never shade enough to there
will always be quite an area
but what is the aim the serenades I
think very a very good very good
question Judith and I think and I think
these are recreational lakes on the edge
of car for you with a subdivision
growing around them you know and I think
they're managed as a district council
asset to maximize human use of them and
they're a park and and so I don't think
we want that I want probably putting
words in your mouth Sophie but I don't
think you wanting to stop people getting
it getting to the edge of the water and
seeing out them out to them
so yeah I think there should be a
clearer management objective of good
access points open water it already is
of course it has been promoted for a
long time as a coarse fishing asset for
better or worse for depending on what
that you know and it's it's it's quite a
good important local to regional asset
and that seeds there's not many other
opportunities but maybe backtracking to
your over can answer is that lakes my
healthiest when they have macro fights
right across their bed and you're on
right with Michael on that's point that
some of that sand objectives because
that basically condenses trapped traps
the sediment stops the nutrients
recycling off the bed so the real
objective we don't want to be harvesting
all the MEK all those macro fights out
of there and having a muddy bed because
there that's how we get sick lakes to
begin with and so we're trying to
maximize a macro fights across the beach
and and then were trying to maximize
human human use values into the
particularly in terms of the margins
and I think that's why
to get all of those we may need to you
know we've been talking about
interventions such as aeration and
things like that because I think the
lakes are getting to the stage where
they cannot fix themselves and
developer resilience healthy system
without some some intervention because
they're isolated because they don't have
an outlet we can't increase the flow or
water flushing through them and things
like that and that's why some monitoring
to verify what the issue is in probably
heading towards a
solution is probably
would set anti-christian to 16
yes I think so I mean
yes I mean I guess I'm looking to for
something that's going to manage them as
a system and not just take off
it's a resilient system anyway we were
through and if we can has to include a
pump you know to keep the oxygen that
and we found that there you know we we
tried adding some sort of phosphorus
locking chemicals to the bed of the
Kuiper Lake subdivisions we were looking
at some more natural solutions of sort
of barley straw extracts and things like
that that they wanted to get that the
carboy Lakes Subdivision wanted to go
down first
they tried those but they met they made
no difference and that we see well we've
probably got to get into a mechanistic
solution such as aeration they tried it
found it worked
they've maintained it it works for them
and I suspect it's probably one of the
only real solutions for these lakes but
we've got to look at all the options and
how it works as a system first
thank you very much that's
Mike Michael one last question then
we'll move on
thank you Michael
are you go Thank You Sophie if you want
to stay there
I think we're going to carry on with you
shortly so I have a recommendation that
this water zone committee received this
update for our information can I have a
mover and a seconder please
Judith
sorry
yep thanks but I'd fall
which is the Ashley wrecker who are
coastal streams update was so she elm
and Marie Isaac new are you near too
[Music]
you know these these
any questions on that will we move on
quick question on the living streams
report does anybody know if the photos
in it refer sort of located relocatable
I mean three the position of the
photographs in the living streams report
you you were so much younger than a
dream well I wasn't looking in
development
presumably you know the originals are
somewhere on file do you think possibly
it might be there just a very good
baseline yeah unless somebody wrote it
on the back of the printer basically
it's this predated the sort of
earthquakes sort of sort of sourcing
those earlier things can be difficult at
times but Wilson if you're really
interested in this report which I think
well yeah I mean just thinking of there
no I think we go and I use a very good
baseline what's it looking like 15 17
years later
yeah that's something um it's not a
sorry no I mean that she can wear was
the photo taken sorry yes
jo grf yep yeah just so you can go and
look at it now to make it yeah it is
something to look at in the sense of
maybe a motivation for you thinking -
Judith like the qe2 covenants isn't it
they sit up very good tracing from
points so you can you've got a baseline
I guess to the reference in terms of
change over time so yeah we might follow
the other contributors to that we're
moving on this is the fantastic
floodplain map which again we've got a
large AO sized one that we use for the
meeting back in October but just to give
the committee a reference
I think everyone that's seen it has
realized it's a pretty primary reference
for the giving an idea of the
geomorphology of the area so it's a
pretty powerful map so actually a sofa
clicks through the next one for the
people the back of the room will get a
slightly better view of it so it gives
like it's a real feel for an Adrian man
or so if you may want to speak to that
in terms of just the geomorphology
topography of the area that makes this
quite a unique part of the district you
know this this when I when I first found
this floodplain geomorphology met that
really reinforced a lot of the sort of
conceptual ideas I had of the system
particularly down on that cut this coast
it's showing these parallel sand dune
systems and the wetlands between and
things like that and it really
illustrates how unique this area as why
it's like it is and what it probably was
historically but equally it's also
showing the breakout point why the were
cuckoo stream and Taranaki Taranaki
Creek and things so they're like they
are because they're following the paths
of old breakout channels from the Ashley
River down into this into and through
these Jun systems so it reads like this
this met resonates with me and other
people particularly Greg burns from the
from there from the coastal Trust got
very excited and was very pleased to be
able to take away an anal
very large map of this because it
resonated with him as well so for those
people that really like maps and that
likely systems you know this is a great
map for probably explaining why this
environment we're trying to manage is
like it is thanks Harry drink the next
map was reflective of a bit of work that
Anna Veltman from the zone delivery team
at Environment Canterbury put in just to
give the committee a bit of a feel for
the number of properties we're talking
about and a sense of scale of them in
this sub catchment area so you'll see
from that slide that the light green and
we can go to the next slides larger but
the light green of the five properties
in the Syria that's and you can see them
relative to the waterways better on this
slide and the pink excuse me the pink
ones are ones that are likely to need
canned farm land use consents so that
the green ones do need and have I think
Leah news content so it just gives the
sense of and it's something we touched
on earlier in terms of who we're talking
to it gives a sense of scale relative to
waterways so that was a wee bit of his
work over lockdown just to pull that met
together as a reference that's the
current status it's it's now who's
consents yeah so yep so it says it
stands is it present
can I ask you may not be out answer this
but the pink farms so though the maybes
what are they needing to be consented on
is it irrigation or is that wintering
you're right that I don't know I
couldn't answer that with any confidence
I don't know I could look at Andrew but
Andrews probably rightly shaken as well
well Yannick and I can answer that
question
the next the next map is really just
another reference for the committee that
reinforces kind of what we've talked
about across the workshop and and this
may be today so in terms of where the
last map was now this is the proposed
coastal protection zone and that's
probably an important whether they
obviously relates to plan change seven
that's what's gone through not
necessarily defined in that way by this
committee but it's the way it's gone
through the hearing and we wait and see
what comes of that but again it just
shows that some if you look at the the
wider saltwater creek catchment as
Caroline was touching on earlier today
and this coastal streams sub catchment
it's all within that proposed so it
again it defines another layer I guess
of what we're looking at potentially
over time you sort of came I think that
this slide answers your question is that
within these coastal protection zones
when it's a farms beyond a certain size
it triggers needing a yeah yeah
conceived a firm
the next resource that I've handed out
so the committee is some of which some
of the company members will know that
have this in their files from the zipper
development phase but um one of the
things that is a tremendous resource in
the same way as that the Mahone Nui Ely
management plans which I think cover
from the why our through to the y ahora
I think off the top of my head it's
written and printed and published in
2013 so there's also a chapter on the
Waimakariri as well and I might talk to
her apart or about it would be great
actually to get you at least an online
copy of the whole thing but this other
that the Y Maori chapter would be
another good one to include for the
committee as well so I might do another
version of referencing that for you but
I've just given you the recovery section
at the stage because again it it's a
fairly foundational resource for us in
terms of looking at night to Hariri
values and an enormous amount of work
was obviously put in at the time that we
management plan was put together so
that's the most relevant section if you
like of it there larger work this is
much as Anna did some good work on that
map so if you did some really good work
here just pointing together a summary
from the coastal drainage advisory group
and the community board so so if you can
probably speak to this I just grabbed
you've also got a two-page summary of
the key points of feedback from both
those groups and you notice in the
smallest of the things I gave you but
that was just a way of flavor that's so
if you can probably have that you on yes
this is a summary of a summary so
hopefully the document that Marius
provided his though the full summary
which gives a bit more flavour there
quite a few different
shoes but the main one of course with
the drainage Advisory Group is the
drainage issues well I was quite
surprised going through the minutes from
that group is how wide their their
concerns were they did bring out quite a
few things about biodiversity and water
quality and so yeah there was a very
good quality information from those
those landowners that we can refer you
to the minutes as well if you want the
details yes so the were concerns about
lake pegasus with the obviously with the
algal blooms very similar to the kaya
point lakes there's been blooms there
with the same same species so algal
species and that same conflict of people
not wanting those weeds and the lake for
model yachts to better use that or for
recreational use but also people wanting
the weeds for the for the health of the
lake so they're very similar to high
point lakes like it's probably just with
a bit of an update for the zone
committee on where things are at with
the lake so it's changed hands a few
times as the town has so originally it
was infinity group owned the Pegasus
development which included the lake
infinity ended ended up in Todd the
hands of Todd's who have relatively
recently sold it to another private
equity Templeton group so all through
that it probably hasn't helped in terms
of advancing the issues with the lake
the good news is there they've all
retained the same consultant so Golders
have been the water quality scientists
that have been engaged by the previous
owners and they have been engaged by
Templeton we've had quite a lot of
discussions both Waimakariri District
Council the one of the reasons we're so
interested in keeping involved in it as
eventually the lake world visa
and the council so the district plan
requires that there happen
and so we're been we've been quite
active and I've actually been talking to
Templeton this morning as recently as
that and they are going to be meeting
with our chief executive in Mia
later this week and we've been pressing
pretty hard to get discussions underway
regarding what's going to happen about
trying to improve the water quality so
this there's a couple of key issues it
is so if you pointed out so there's
assistance stratification and the lake
so very similar to that diagram that was
shown for the Khoikhoi lakes that the
work that's been done over the years has
shown that that definitely is an issue
and Pegasus Lake and there's also been
the toxic algal blooms and we've just
been through the longest and most
persistent bloom to date it started
earlier than it has before I think it
even started before Christmas and it's
only just must only be about a month ago
or so that that was actually given the
all-clear which now that means it's not
compliant with a couple of consents
condition so these consent conditions
for the like they'd refer to not
allowing it to stratify and the other
one is to not have be persistent and
recurrent toxic algal blooms so it's
having both of those on our environment
cannery have taken some enforcement
action against the owners including
finding them so look we're just and
we're we're really at the stage where
we're very keen and we're pushing pretty
hard to try and get some kind of action
so that it is going to be either any
trials or anything carried out that
that's put in place in advance of the
summer and the sorts of things are
exactly the types of things that were
shown for the carboy lakes where
potentially aeration could be put in
place
the main purpose for actually doing that
wouldn't be necessary to
oxygenator because Pegasus Lake is
fortunate it's quite open to wind and it
does teamed to get oxygenated and by
those natural the natural wind but it's
more to try and remove their
stratification just by turning the water
over and we believe that will help would
help in terms of stopping a
stratification and also trying to
prohibit those toxic algal bloom so and
we've got a pegasus residents
association meeting that we're gun
councils been invited to on wednesday
night and there's no doubt that'll be a
topic of conversation and all the
questions that have come and have been
you know there's a whole pile of things
it's all around roads and traffic as
well as community facilities but a lot
of the feedback is around the lake this
the other thing is the lake it's always
important to remember it was never
intended for primary contact recreation
so the original consent was issued for
secondary common secondary recreation
which is just things like boating and
kayaking never for swimming but
unfortunately a lot of the marketing and
early days gave that perception and it
was actually really when it was very
very new water body it was great it was
a great swimming facility and but it is
where it is now
and I just want to really assure you
that Environment Canterbury staff and
Waimakariri District Council staff are
working very actively and we really want
to cooperate with the new owners we've
actually got so I talked about Golda's
golden has been engaged by all of the
owners the council has got petal del
amor on board so they've been advising
us on our site as well so they've been
doing peer review work and as well
Environment Canterbury including
Adrienne have been really
very helpful and helping us understand
the science behind the lake and
certainly been far more than just acting
as a you know extend back regulator but
I've been really proactive which has
been fantastic so yeah happy to take any
questions on them
getting you right okay great so just
looking now with all that knowledge
we've gained of the always documents
have dredged up from years past where
are some these gaps and I think yeah
there I stalled knowledge gaps for
example if we're looking at the invasive
fish Rudd and the Taranaki stream we
don't actually know how just have how
the extent of it
population is and we have water carried
out works which unlucky stream
floodgates back and we can see a couple
of months ago fibrin debris thank you
thank you and Fabrice oh I believe that
monitoring is taking place to see the
figures absolutely of the fish window so
yeah what essentially the old floodgate
was was was somewhat warped the seals
have gone on it so they era room river
managers basically built and built a new
flood gate put it in it and while they
put the new flood gate in they've built
a sort of fish window to a sort of trial
for fish passage as well but we've gone
being going through a process of both
first just proving how it held what an
improvement it is having a new flood
gate that seals well first before we
start opening the fish screen and then
seen whether that has a detrimental
effect on drainage and flood levels and
there and also what positive effect it
has on fish passage but it so it's a
stepwise process but it's quite exciting
great something else but it's been
flagged as well the other part of did
mention a couple of meetings ago about a
particular waterway that we're child
talking have been taken to be drowned
and I think that really resonated with
people that there's a lot of history in
this area that is very war and the
understanding that we need to take movie
on and take work in this area is very
important and we need to bring the
community along with us to understand
that history and so
there's a lot more that needs to be
understood I think and that's a
different get process skips so we should
go for people which program together now
would a important catchment group be the
best way forward or some sort of formal
trust or land cute group some existing
structure or a new one and or end or
many managing some projects through the
zone committee can in WDC so these are
all the gaps we need to start thinking
about what we as a best best agency to
organization to mend achieve any
projects and programs and lastly
prioritization so there are there's a
lot of a lot of spending to buy in this
process of gathering the knowledge but
suddenly yeah we have just look at how
do we prioritize it so onto the next
step should I carry on Mary are you
right
so the proposal from from the staff at
ich NW dcs to her quadrupled bottom
lines that's the qvl approach
environmental cultural social and
economic and what I'm proposing was very
similar actually to in the living
streams report from 2003 I was quite
surprised I saw this after I put this
together we're ahead a very similar
process where I think group we've sort
of on that chain or really you know I
think we could almost embrace that
living streams process and yeah we just
have disguised aside how the structure
and their work program go formal
recommendation from the zone committee
and then look at prioritization and
project ideas using the QBL approach
that's what steps you so reconvening the
discussion group from the Caroline and
others have been pulling together with
the great consultation with the
landowners in the area
to discuss what's the best structure it
was a question we brought to them beckon
it was October year so again and
discussing this and looking at what
techniques we thought will show you one
of the things - that's probably of value
is just to reconvene that group and just
have another chicken with him you know
given times ellipse but we've got a wee
bit more shaped what we're looking to do
now so we thought that could be a good
step to take in advance of what follows
there as well in terms of talking it's
okay
they'll like there what we touched on
before is Sofie touched from the
previous workshop where our powder had
suggested that some field trips may be
in the spring to pass on some of that
cultural Looney would be a good option
so I think that I'm sure we'd all be
interested in that and there could be
something to be looked at sort of
september/october great I also have done
some work we cleanse our maps by
Environment Canterbury and we this
potential for work projects let's
something up circulated informally but
I'm happy to pull together in a more
formal format and bring to the zone
committee you know a report talked about
an updated stream walk so that's the
living streams question of can we get
updated photos and see what's happened
since the Great's of chicken and what's
what has been happening and what's not
happening and maybe then why and finally
looking at if a catchment group is the
right way he'd you know how to support
that and yeah it could be a combination
of different work structures it could be
that there are multiple parties working
together multiple organizations that are
working in the catchment certainly I
think it's the stream walk option I
guess is not a simple or an expensive
one but I think the way we've discussed
that in terms of replicating the living
streams approach
as a Sophie's touched on could be a very
good way to look at that because we've
already got there that reference from
the work done 17 years ago so so again
hopefully that's a useful reference for
you as a committee to sort of review
over the next week or two any questions
the message I took from both of those is
that they keen to do things their own
way on their own land and this seems
like while I'm at District Council and
ECAM coming in from above with a plan
and the program and I just wonder I
don't think you've had the chance to
talk about how those two things might
fit together yeah cause it was my comedy
right having multiple organizations or
entities that could be farmers
themselves making sure this space the
solution could be a bit more reading
together approach where you you have
multiple parties that all working on the
same song sheet but not telling them you
know this is what you're gonna do this
is our plan and you're going to do this
so yeah that's a question for the zone
committee is how to make that work
Angie's gonna chip in mister ABS
hello um I think probably what needs to
be remembered it's great work that um
these guys and his mother's around and
fought together was actually this was a
response to a request for more
information what already exists going
back a step from there was which still
hasn't really been answered what does a
catchment based approach which my
understanding is certainly is that the
successful ones when you look across New
Zealand or internationally if the
successful ones are informed but from
the grassroots action which is lining up
with you're saying so that's probably
where this discussion needs to lead to
is how do we have a program that
actually takes us information and feeds
it through that doesn't feel like
basically you're dumping it on people
yeah that brings it through
one of the reasons were suggesting we
reconvene with that group we met
informally back in October last year of
community boards and locally announced
drainage advisory groupers to achieve
exactly there that it keeps it kind of
inclusive and with some direction in
terms of what people prepared to support
so one of the things that I recall from
that conversation was that in terms of
what we've got there that maybe a trust
or something we set up and and I think
several people said don't worry about
that actually the zone committee can
play a role being a hub of the wheel and
they can take a lot of time and effort
to set up and our preference at the
stage would be not to do that that
wasn't saying no to catchment groups but
saying maybe not to a formal structure
so um so again I think that's the value
of just going back and checking back in
with that group as we go periodically
zero-risk is we've got a lot of reports
here and to sort of prevent a continual
cycle of just updating of reports and
more action groups we try and start a
catchment Medical Group and he gets too
big and we try and build something
that's perfect from day one and it kind
of takes too long and we have to update
all the reports again I mean is it a
case of starting with like what
Caroline's done with particular groups
in in just when you've got an immediate
issue or a immediate problem which is
where a lot of these catchment
management groups start with it's pretty
you know generally it's a pretty obvious
problem that brings people together to
start with and work on that and then
build it up into something bigger a
little bit like what the zone can be
started with you know we've we started
off with some very specific problems in
our branch and for a lot more so I don't
know whether it's just feedback as part
of the process that instead of trying
here again get everyone under the room
and working out what the formal
structure is and one of the activities
and who's going to be responsible for
what that it's a case of well what are
they we've got a range of immediate
actions or or issues already identified
here and I'm sure most of them still
exist around assigning some
responsibility with the council's with
zone committees with you know
particularly farmers and their local
areas that instead of everyone trying to
wrap their head around every issue
that's the year that we just do what we
can in hopefully you know be great if it
did evolve into something that was sort
of
and an overarching but to start with
that I think we it's just going to take
too long too much resource and it's just
not going to be enough done you know if
just just an opinion you know I think
there's probably room for but you know
how and when they get themselves
organized they might be doing it now or
they might not either way akin and WDC
still need to be boxing on so you know I
kind of feel like for you guys isn't the
best thing for you to be focusing on the
public land and the attachment and and
coming up with projects for the public
land and then you know if you've got
like your local park planting broke down
at work or ku or you've got a farmer's
catchment group and then you know you
all sort of keep each other informed as
to what you're doing and in in doubt
blazing however kind of works the Beast
but yeah everyone's gotta get started
and like you're saying came that's
perhaps not going to be from one point
that they get started so yeah
you know it would be nice to be able to
I guess if it would help get that
taranaki work or culotte organized and
together to be able to go to them and
say well you know WDC for example are
pressing on with projects on various
bits of lend a new catchment that they
own would be great to have your input on
those projects for example that might
sort of serve as a bit of a catalyst to
pull them together so just to go back to
the workshop we had earlier about
funding opportunities I mean now is
different the time to enable and that's
a catalyst that we can use to spring
would work on private land in particular
then I think there's a good time to
debate to provide information and advice
and and help with funding applications
potentially
you know I think we need to fill in the
gaps you know I think you know like I
think I've been here too long because I
think I've got about three or four
different copies of the same sort of
information this will just receive today
and I think we need to fill in the gaps
in today's exercise for me was really
cool because when out on fire
we're hey look farmers are there there's
a lot of history in that area the lake
bill woke Wilson who was a who was a
member of this committee I was heavily
involved in the little Ashley and the
water care group that they had in that
area there there's been six extensive
plantings and extensive work that's
already been done so basically and they
won an award through fishing game for
some of the work that they've done we've
got to fill in the gaps and the gaps
that we have and the farmers have is in
relation and in relation to their
cultural expectations and in particular
mahegger koi we need some education on
that we also need to educate the farmers
on that we also need to educate the
people that are doing the audits and
preparing the farm of our plants that's
a big gap so I think that's where we
need to focus this workshop on we need
to build on the good relationships that
we have with the farmers and when you
look at this map that's been prepared by
an development you can see that the
majority of those those guys are
consented there's not many guys that we
need to work with in order to make that
happen I don't think we need to have
another workshop or another plan in
order to get things happen what we need
to do is action the plans and we need to
do that we've got already work with
those handful of guys that we've got
there get some funding in and get stuff
happening sorry don't be sorry Dave can
you take two minutes and add to what you
just said just recap your your field
visits today please basically zone lead
Marco Kent Alenia myself visited most of
these guys packed and green on this map
this morning with the view to getting
some stuff done in relation to the
Taranaki Creek Taranaki stream little
Ashley in the walk will go straight
was really good because we could see
some of the good work that the farmers
had already started to do in particular
Tim Delaney on the right hand side as
you're traveling north on State Highway
one towards the Ashley bridge and he
also has a property on the left as well
and it's really cool to see the stuff
that's being done as being lead but he's
transferred one of the other farms on
the left-hand side from Frontera to
Sunday supply and is looking forward to
moving that property towards sin lay
lead with pride and as part of that they
have an environmental pillar which is
buying into and requires ongoing
commitment to the environment so that's
really cool so in relation to the
Fonterra funding that we've got we're
looking at progressing and filling in
the gaps along those waterways and I
think that that is a really good start
to what we're seeing and of the farmers
that we approached there was only one
that was negative towards what we were
trying to achieve so basically we were
at now is that ek and staff in a Veldman
in Sapporo clog will visit those farmers
and prepare some plans and then we also
had a workshop today of which Kate
Steele and Sophie indicator that they
would assist those farmers in trying to
fast-track some funding so we can get
some more funding from some of the
government funded things and mr. money
man here mr. Andrew apps will I'm sure
find some other sources of income for
those projects and the farmers were keen
to invest in those projects themselves
so I think it's really cool and what we
need to do as a committee is we need to
fill in the gaps
and the gaps are the lack of knowledge
regarding the cultural side of it
because they simply don't know and
that's a real education thing that I
look forward to because it's something
that I need to like learn about to know
it is all in there but it's it's not
just in there and needs to happen on the
ground we need to have that discussion
around what it means around mahegger coy
and like I say I don't know
with their you know it's part of our
order to training we're to spend time
and in the right I think it would be
good for zone company members to do
exactly the same I think you have to do
that as part of it being a counselor as
well day and it would be good because
then you have to some understanding of
those values and it's and it's really
cool because that's a big gap here
because I so it's and it's one of the
things that it's pretty that era powers
not here because I think he gets upset
about it because the lack of
understanding in in regard to making a
koi and also into cultural
considerations I think there's a big gap
Thank You mr. Ashby Sophie anything else
yeah Ellie drew you know just coming to
Andrew you've got two minutes I'm just
wondering if we pips taken action based
on these points and I'm sort of doing
that on the fly but essentially your
inner end is it for doing that piece
Macrina will be involved in that as well
with those farmers and we use those five
odd landowners as should we say the
first steps towards what will become a
catchment based approach and so they
effectively kind of just what you said
cam as far as this get some runs on the
board with them and then use them as the
showcase to or the catalyst for the rest
of the of the catchment and we'll come
back to you with an update on that
there's quite an immediate action will
be into that on the next um weeks few
weeks oh by the Knicks own committee I
think we'll see some see some action
because that's probably important one is
is pickups being said a number of
reports but it's actually tuning it
under the action as the end delivery yep
thank you Andy that Michael just a quick
one from you
planting all need to look pretty that's
nice
Thank You Kim
sorry mr. Jo still a Monica and so just
going back to those Knicks tips we
talked about you were talking about
reconvening the discussion group and I
guess who should are in the process
going forward do you have any
recommendations on that are you handing
this back to us now for us to drive
forward or resist of a vision that we
would do it really I think it is a
decision for the zoning committee from
here particularly to make a
recommendation back to Environment
Canterbury in WDC because I think it is
a very important decision and maybe it's
a decision that you might agree that
there should be not your decision
it should be a private here for
landowners for example but that's a
decision that you need to make because
of the structure of how a pretty good
progress from here is quite important
yeah I think that's best for your the
zone can be to make mr. chair Dewey
when do we want to schedule it it makes
me I'm thinking if we receive the report
national and then we can have that
conversation as an image workshop yep
everybody happy covering that topic
tonight yep all righty
so that's agenda item number 4 which is
the HD record who are coastal streams
update
the zone committee receives us update
for information and supporting committee
sub catchment engagement and action
planning - I have a mover please cam
Sikandar John all those in favor
Thank You Murray item five there's are
some of those you can take as read
[Music]
so the first one regards proposed plane
change seven so as I do each month I
conferred with Fleming team for the
latest wording in terms of where the the
process is it so you'll see that the
major change there is that the
independent Hearing Panel hasn't yet set
a date but it is looking towards
September or early October to convene
the hearing so that's the primary point
there just in regard to that seeing that
the human of the commissioners lives in
Australia my understanding is this he's
made it reasonably clear that the
planning staff that they should make
arrangements for him to either Microsoft
teams in or whatever so he is given an
indication that he would like to proceed
and preps do it from afar so the
planning team where I think have been
charged with looking at how to make that
viable give him the covert realities
well let that one play out yeah we'll
let the planning team work through the
logistics but I think they've been
instructed to make it happen I'm sure
there are any other questions on that
one the next one is communications
update and Angus has provided just a
couple of items there by way of just a
reference for the committee of the most
immediate things that have occurred
including some feedback Markos provided
with regards to Ravenswood and the use
of coconut mating me
so just came up with a local media angus
given that you're in the back of the
room is there anything you want to cover
specifically let's forget the comms
update
the next item is with regards to
increasing nitrate nitrogen trends and
Christchurch wells an ember who was in
the back of the room has provided way to
agenda item 5.2 which actually gives a
response this was a question that Sandra
asked at the previous meeting and amber
has provided that memo as you'll see on
pages 14 and 15 so I don't know if there
are any questions with regards to what
Amber's provided there and where their
environs to speak to it at all
I lied any particular points Caroline
[Music]
they could work out with yeah there are
three locations now that have deep wells
on three different levels about 15
metres 100 metres 150 metres one
location north of the river and two
locations south of the river
they have been installed in 2018 so they
have not been included in this because
they need to have a certain amount of
samples to be included in trend analysis
yeah so we have yeah so they are
included now and we are also looking
into installing an even deeper bore
around three or four hundred metres deep
it will give you a lot
yes that's all yeah cutting up some more
information around because I just
vestigation yeah yeah because these
samples basically are based on nitrate
concentrations so on those alone you
can't really make a conclusion like that
yeah yeah so that's we have the morning
and then future monitoring as well
[Music]
thanks Amy
the next items just following up on the
immediate steps biodiversity funding
approach and as I provide to the
committee earlier I thought the easiest
way to respond to that is to actually
provide supporters presentation from
October last year which gave a fairly
substantive overview of both the
committee's approach and successes
really in terms of utilizing the media
chips funding over the last decade so if
there's any questions relative to that
but I thought having consulted was
sapore that was the I guess had been
generated a good resources to keep using
it was a reference the other thing if
there's no questions on there it's just
the regional committee I think Carolyn
can add if if there's any fear that
breaking news but some that's it to make
this month is that right for the first
time since we breathe and the other
thing that I've emailed through to the
committee and I have hard copies sitting
back at the office the one thing I
didn't bring the the zone committee
review June update and survey analysis
reports are they mailed you all their
copy which just gives you a bit of
additional information in terms of those
committee members across the region that
had replied to the survey help what sort
of questions you know or help how they
feedback on those questions so I've got
a hard copy of that for you all if you'd
like it if you're happy with the online
version that's fine as well so in the
final thing is the letter from mr. Craig
Macintosh that Michael received so I've
highlighted the questions that he's post
I will follow up on those questions
because I have done so previously for
Craig he possibly didn't like the
answers and thought if I asked them
again maybe I get a different answer but
I did respond to those with the the
technical memos that the committee had
at the time of developing their zipper
and the information that's in the zipper
itself which is effectively what Craig's
asked for so so if you're like I've kept
it in the context of the zip addendum
but I will go back to Craig and to see
if he had like the same memos again or
war-weary what's through the
clarification questions armory oh yeah
so I have a recommendation that we
confirm they don't come back wonder that
we've received these updates and with
reference to the committee's 2020 work
program and community engagement project
priorities five point one which is the
consent to farming campaign 2025 point
to an answer to count Salah Stewart's
question on nitrite twin trends do I
have a mover please Caroline and
Sikandar Dave all those in favor
thinking ugh rowdy item number six which
is confirming the minutes from the
previous meeting which was held over
zoom on the 8th of June can I have a
mover and a seconder please to confirm
that these minutes are true and accurate
records Dave Sikandar John matters
arising
I have one here from Council of Stuart's
so she could head this correction please
paragraph 18 sorry page 18 paragraph 4
should read councillor Stewart enquired
how he can could be dealing with the
applications that did not strictly
adhere to the immediate steps criteria
the word not is missing please it mean
if we could make that adjustment that
would be good
any other matters corker item 7 general
business Bingen nothing to add not
really at this stage obviously a new
plan has gone through now
so we getting now into long term plan
can't count to break this week in next
week those long term pre-planned
briefings and planning moving forward
will be continuing the only other thing
that I will flag with you is coastal
plan was funded through the annual
animal beginning of starting that
process I'm so look out for in the
future
mr. Henderson Thank You mr. Blackwell I
understand that it is likely that we
will see the NPS aeneas for freshwater
at some stage over July I'm just
wondering whether we could get an update
as soon as he can is able on the
implications of that document Despero
information I'm looking at Angus at the
back of the room and I'm doing that with
great enthusiasm because he generators
not only he but there was a response on
the day of the earlier announcement so I
assume that there will be similar energy
put into a response very quickly yes
they did last time
cool Michael thank you for those photos
it was actually quite pleasing to see
some nice photos for a change just out
of interest the one you took when you
were up at sticks no some imagery dear
which it was quite close to where that
lamprey spawning site was that got wiped
out was there any evidence of that
coming back
okay thank you I think we're almost here
ladies and gentlemen and this is
anything else I'd just like to cover a
couple points there's a bit of history
here now that's interesting so for you
bringing up you know where are the gaps
and what we're trying to do because it's
a frustrating process when I first
signed up to join the zone committee I
was talking to a local ringer you're a
person who happened to be involved in
consulting of this report and he was
very disparaging because he said don't
waste your time all you do is create
reports but you don't actually make any
difference
so so the challenge we have which I
think was starting to make progress is
translating those reports and into
action and Dave your visit today is
incredibly heartening because I think
that's the linkages which we as a zoning
committee helping us as linking the
community to the process to the outcome
and all we can do is keep doing our best
in that regard
Stephen sorry I hope you went near a
started meeting because I didn't see it
tucked away but would you be so kind as
to finish the meeting with a karakia
place
thank you very much well rowdy our next
meeting is scheduled for the 3rd of
August which is quite fortuitous because
it's my birthday so I might have to
share so thank you all for your
attendance
[Music]